the u.n security council is preparing to
meet an emergency session to discuss the
military coup in myanmar
the u.s is threatening to reimpose
sanctions to try to force the generals
to stand down
myanmar's former de facto leader aung
san sochi was detained and
hundreds of officials are confined
inside government housing compounds
the military claims november's election
results which
showed a landslide win for suchi's
ruling party
were fraudulent the current head of the
u.n security council
discussed her expectations of the
emergency session
we'll want to have as constructive a
discussion as possible
on myanmar and look at a range of
measures with the idea
of respecting the people's will
expressed in the vote
and releasing civil society and civil
society leaders
i think those will be our overriding
aims
and we'll want to consider measures that
will
uh move us towards that and we've got
dave
grunibaum on the line now he's a
journalist who spent many years
reporting from myanmar and he joins us
now from
kuala lumpur so dave the coup
has drawn condemnation from many
countries the us
is threatening sanctions is that likely
to have any effect
on the coup leaders these these these
these sanctions they get along the
bottom line but they're unlikely to have
any impact on the uh decisions that the
general makes
because or any of the generals make
because they've been through this for
decades in the past during the military
junta
and it had very little impact the real
concern would be if there are
broad-based economic sanctions that have
huge impact on the overall economy of
myanmar which could take
these people most of whom live in
absolute poverty and make
things even worse for them so that's the
calculation that has to be made by the
west would they really want to risk
have that happening the key player here
and a key question is how does china
respond because during the days of the
dictatorship
the china was their best friend and
china could make some maneuvers here to
ease the economic pressure on them so
china's response to any economic
sanctions could have a real impact on
things
what about the de facto civilian leader
aung san tsuchi
we understand she's under house arrest
again she's calling on her supporters to
resist
is there any sign that her supporters
are heeding
that call well well clearly they
they they want they are with her and she
has the she's the most beloved person
in the country the question though is
would these people be willing to risk
repercussions
if they were to make public
demonstrations will we at some point see
mass demonstrations in the streets of
yangon the biggest city in the country
that's a real question because in the
past if you look at past history
the military they would sometimes put
down these types of revolts often
violently often with deadly
force another thing to to question here
is
a lot of the leading activists in this
country the people who would organize
these sorts of demonstrations
even some of the people who did this
back in the 80s who are very much looked
up to
some of these activists in the country
have been detained and some of the
others have gone into hiding
so it's really hard to wonder right now
who would be the people who would leave
these types of demonstrations
if the public were to try to do it
anytime soon
you talked about the military cracking
down there are also serious concerns
about the situation
of the rohingya muslims in the country
what consequences
could this coup have for them well
the rohingya who live in the country uh
almost overwhelmingly in northern
northwestern rakhine state
what has been a horrible situation for
them for decades
this makes it even worse the military
was repressive on them to begin with
keep in mind the rohingya are stateless
they had their citizenship
stripped in the 1980s uh this just makes
matters worse and then if you go
over the border several years ago more
than 700 000 rohingya
muslims fled myanmar for neighboring
bangladesh due to a military crackdown
that has led to accusations of genocide
any hopes that any significant number of
them would be repatriating
you know any time this year this just
seems to completely
dash that because why would they want to
go back to the country that is now
completely ruled
by the same military that drove them out
and killed by some estimates more than
10 000 of them
dave thank you very much for your
insights that was journalist dave
grunibaum talking to us from kuala
lumpur
calm amidst the political storm
people in the city of yangon adjusting
to a new reality
of military rule a state of emergency
has been declared for one year
despite calls for resistance by former
de facto leader aung sang-soo-chi
residents of myanmar's largest city are
we've hesitant for 72 hours but people
won't go on the street in protest
everyone knows the military has guns and
they are used to shooting people
i think people will find another way to
protest
we are very timid and we can't say
anything
i'm afraid of them
many international leaders have
expressed alarm
over the coup the u.s underscored its
support for democracy in myanmar
also known as burma after saying it was
quote
taking note of those who stand with the
people of burma
in this difficult hour i think it's a
message to
all countries in the region and
countries who you know will be asked
to respond or to consider what the
appropriate response will be
in reaction to the events that have
happened over the past couple of days
in the capital napieta hundreds of
lawmakers are confined in government
housing complexes
which are being guarded by soldiers
the military said seizing power was
necessary
after the government failed to act on
claims of election fraud
on facebook the ruling national league
for democracy party appealed to the
military to free those detained and to
honor november's election results
which handed the nld a landslide victory
they were the second democratic
elections in myanmar
after a transition from decades of
military rule
now there are fears the country could
slide back to its old ways
and for more on that let's bring in
felix hydoc he is a researcher for the
asia division at swp the german
institute for international and security
affairs
welcome to the program and thank you for
joining us do you see a path out of this
political crisis in myanmar
at the moment not really to be honest um
the coup
um has created a new status quo
um as you already alluded to
the nld leadership de facto has been
detained
um there's military uh patrolling this
key areas in key cities uh at the moment
i don't see
really a way out i also do not see
the military reacting to international
pressure that will come one way or the
other via the u.n
via the eu the us and other states and
organizations um but
current currently um i do not see a
quick way out no
why is that um i'd like to ask you why
you're skeptical about the results that
international uh pressure
can have in myanmar because you know
over the past years we have seen mixed
results from the international community
on myanmar
there was limited action following the
crackdown against rohingya muslims for
example in the country in
in 2017 is it just because of a lack of
consistency with regard to myanmar
or is it something else
well i think it's not a monocausal in
the sense that there are
i think at least two main factors here
not just one
one being surely there's inconsistent
messaging
there are there are countries like um
like china um who are
more reserved than other countries
but there's also if you look closer
there's the asean the association of
south east asia
where you can already see a split
between countries like
malaysia indonesia and others who are
more
forceful when it comes and more and more
inside the coup and there's other
countries
if already if you can check the
statements by the
thai government but also by the
philippines who kind of treat it as an
internal affair and and kind of shy
away from putting pressure
on myanmar so even on this and that's
the one factor the other factor is
domestic
um there is a long history of the
uh the um burmese military
uh being in one way or the other immune
to international criticism and
and sanctions i mean the country has
basically existed as
the pariah state for decades and in the
in the in the in the eye
in the means of many in the military and
many conservatives in the country
been doing all right with that so it
wouldn't surprise me if this
mentality and this outlook um will also
one way or the other determine the the
the actions and the interests of the
current military leadership in myanmar
felix heideck from the german institute
for international and security affairs
thank you so much
thanks for having me